[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous
merci d'être là moi je voudrais déjà
vous dire que c'est un grand honneur
pour moi d'être ici aujourd'hui de venir
vous parler parce qu'en général dans ce
genre de conférence bien vous écouter
des experts des scientifiques y aura des
prix nobel moi je suis là surtout en
tant que maman alors qu'est ce que j'ai
à vous dire si je ne suis que cela eh
bien je vais vous raconter surtout la
manière dont je communique avec mon fils
famille faut déjà que je vous dise que
je suis la maman de deux enfants
complètement différent marco et sami
famille il est autiste il est
épileptique
il est polyhandicapé alors vous vous en
doutez il ya eu et il y aura encore
beaucoup de douleur de larmes ça c'est
pour le côté difficile de l'histoire
mais il ya aussi un apprentissage mutuel
des découvertes une leçon pour que des
personnes différentes arrive à
communiquer entre elles
vous savez quand on communique il faut
des mots moi mon fils ils ne parlent pas
et je ne suis jamais sûr de ce qu'il va
comprendre
là je suis en train de vous parler
j'utilise des codes des références qu'on
a tous en commun vous êtes en train
d'écouter des sons j'ai des expressions
j'ai une gestuelle tout ça ça nous sert
de référence et c'est très pratique et
c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à se
comprendre même parfois sans parler la
même langue avec un enfant handicapé
autistes ça ne marche pas c'est qu'au
delà il n'a pas été capable de les
apprendre et il ne vous apprendra jamais
alors dans ce cas là c'est à nous de
nous mettre à son niveau son niveau de
compréhension son rythme c'est à nous
d'essayer de voir comment lui il voit le
monde
je vais d'abord vous présenter ça me
quand je lui parle vous voyez il ne me
regarde pas en fait c'est quelque chose
qui lui est très difficile je ne sais
pas pourquoi mais il ne peut pas
regarder les autres ça lui demande un
effort énorme mais si lui ne peux pas me
regarder moi je peux le faire vous
pouvez le regarder on peut tous y
arriver et ce regard là il est très
important alors ça prend du temps ça
prend de l'énergie mais grâce à ça j'ai
fini par établir une sorte de
communication avec lui et même par
téléphone ça marche il ne parle pas mais
j'ai de vraies conversations avec lui à
la maison mon mari mon fils aîné ont
l'habitude de se moquer de moi parce
qu'il m'entende lui parle et je bout
d'un moment je dis c'est vrai ça me met
c'est chouette ça avait l'air génial ta
journée alors qu'en fait lui il n'a fait
que des ba ba ba ba mais le rythme de
ces baba ses intonations sa respiration
même on indiqué beaucoup de choses et
j'ai réussi à le comprendre et moi c'est
ça aujourd'hui que je voudrais vous
transmettre à tous c'est qu'en faisant
attention à l'autre en l'observant on
peut réussir à dialoguer avec n'importe
qui ou au moins trouver un terrain
d'entente parce que même si on est tous
différent vous savez on est tous pareils
ou inversement d'ailleurs le meilleur
exemple de tout ça c'est la formule 1
qui sert à la voiture de monsieur tout
le monde vous savez mon fils c'est un
peu une formule il est très difficile à
conduire j'ai parfois l'impression de me
livrer un crash test ça peut faire mal
mais en tout cas grâce à lui j'ai
l'impression que j'ai appris à mieux me
conduire avec tout le monde
regarder l'autre c'est vraiment quelque
chose de fondamental on voit pouces on
voit mais on ne regarde pas dans un
autisme très sévères comme celui de sam
image est pas le choix il faut
l'observer beaucoup il faut être en
retrait il faut que j'attende des signes
de sa part qui me disent ok maman tu
peux y aller là maintenant tu peux
entrer en interaction avec moi et à
chaque fois ce moment d'attentes va
m'apprendre énormément vous savez quand
je rentre dans la chambre de mon fils il
n'habite plus avec moi je vais le voir
tous les quinze jours je ne rentre
jamais subitement dans sa chambre et je
ne me jette pas sur lui pour l'embrasser
alors que j'en meurs dans vie eh bien
j'ai pas le choix je commence simplement
par manifester ma présence j'ouvre la
porte je me montre j'utilise où le son
ou l'image jamais les deux en même temps
il n'est pas capable d'appréhender les
deux camps au bout d'un moment il à mon
image j'ajoute le son est là je vais lui
dire toujours la même phrase bonjour mon
amour c'est maman je suis là toujours la
même parce que c'est un repère pour lui
et puis j'attends encore et c'est
seulement quand il est près que je vais
enfin m'avancer et en fait tout ce temps
d'observation moi je vais pouvoir
décrypter chacune de ces expressions un
coup de poing sur la joue ça veut dire
que j'ai surgi dans son champ visuel
bien trop vite je les ai heurté il a
pris peur il peut pas c'est trop tôt si
au contraire il a les yeux en l'air il
piquionne des yeux je sais que là il est
en train de lui même d'observer sans me
regarder mais il observe il est en train
d'attendre de voir ce qui va se passer
après et quand tout d'un coup ils
baissent le visage et que je vois les
très détendue je sais que je peux y
aller il est prêt et ça c'est une
rencontre de l'autre à chaque fois
exceptionnel ce regard là il est
fondamental cinq modes de communication
c'est sûr qu'ils nécessitent de mettre
tous ses sens en alerte je suis face à
quelqu'un qui ne peut pas me dire
verbalement dans quel état il est ce
qu'il ressent émotionnellement il faut
donc que je décrypte et vivre avec la
différence au quotidien et bien c'est ça
c'est interprété en permanence alors
c'est vrai ça oblige à une certaine
patience ça oblige à accepter un autre
rythme à accepter la lenteur des choses
et là c'est un peu un mot tabou
aujourd'hui on a complètement oublié de
prendre notre temps on est tous en train
de courir partout entre le travail les
enfants à la vie quotidienne on n'arrête
pas et en a plus jamais le temps mais
nous par enfant handicapé on n'a pas le
choix finalement on est obligé de se
soumettre à un autre rythme tout le
temps on est obligé de prendre ce temps
là et ce temps là et bien finalement il
nous apprend aussi à écouter les autres
y compris les personnes normales et
c'est très très bien en fait je suis sûr
que vous même tous vous aimeriez être
mieux regarder mieux compris d'ailleurs
on le voit tous les jours vous prenez
des photos et vous les mettez sur les
réseaux sociaux vous exprimez vous vécu
vos ressentis et vous assommer tout le
monde de photos on le fait tous mais
pourquoi pas ce que vous voulez qu'on
vous regarde mais vous savez comment ils
font les gens qui vous regardent sur ces
réseaux sociaux ils scroll ça va à toute
vitesse le temps d'attention qu'il vous
accorde en moyenne la durée d'attention
de quelqu'un sur ses réseaux elle est de
8 secondes
c'est fou non huit secondes en 2000 elle
était de 12 secondes et pour information
la durée d'attention moyenne d'un
poisson rouge à l'est de 9 secondes vous
venez d'apprendre tout valait pas mieux
qu'un poisson rouge je suis désolé ça
fait mal mais c'est la réalité
en fait personne ne vous regarde
vraiment alors que prendre le temps mais
même le temps de s'asseoir de regarder
l'autre lui accorder un moment
pleinement ça va tout changer ce qui est
étonnant c'est qu'on le fait tous très
spontanément avec nos enfants tout petit
vous vous accroupissez à leurs auteurs
pour leur parler et puis curieusement
quand ils grandissent pas nous reste
deux on les regarde et on leur parle de
haut c'est bizarre et en fait tout ce
qu'on fait dans le monde du handicap
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est que
finalement ça daf s'adapte à tout le
monde au quotidien d'ailleurs c'est très
simple vous le voyez des trottoirs
bateau ça a été fait pour les fauteuils
roulants tous les jeunes parents sont
ravis de les avoir pour pousser la
poussette de leur enfant
c'est donc très important de se mettre à
leur niveau et puis c'est important
aussi de savoir tenir respecter une
certaine distance vous savez on a
toujours une impression un petit peu
désagréable quand quelqu'un vient vous
parlez d'un peu trop près comme ça
instinctivement recul il a envahi notre
sphère intime et bien il faut utiliser
vraiment votre empathie votre capacité à
vous mettre à la place de l'autre on
envahit rien tant que l'autre n'en est
pas capable je connais une femme
formidable elle est totalement à l'aise
avec son corps alors elle se balade à
moitié nue chez elle et un jour je lui
faisais remarquer quand même y avait sa
femme de ménage qui étaient là et elle
sa réaction spontanée ça a été de me
dire c'est pas grave ça me gêne pas mais
c'était la femme de ménage qui était
gêné et ça il n'y avait même pas pensé
et en fait on ne peut pas agir avec tout
le monde de la même manière on est tous
différents c'est très important vous
vous êtes normaux disons pas aussi
différents que mon fils samy mais vous
êtes tous différents vous avez tous vos
singularité vos talents vos faille vos
propre rythme et on devrait tous être
capable de les respecter c'est chouette
il faudrait profiter de toutes ces
différences et en fait on passe notre
temps à tout normalisée et ça fonctionne
pas pour bien vivre ensemble
alors c'est vrai que ce serait facile si
on pouvait avoir une sorte de mode
d'emploi qui nous servirait à comprendre
les uns et les autres qu'on n'aurait
plus qu'à suivre tout simplement eh bien
non désolé ça n'est jamais facile parce
que le mode d'emploi que vous croyez
avoir trouvé pour quelqu'un à l'instant
t eh bien le lendemain il sera pas
forcément valable moi avec mon fils je
passe ma vie à l'observer à me dire ça y
est j'ai compris pourquoi là maintenant
il met son bras comme ça il s'apprête à
se taper où j'ai compris pourquoi ils
regardent comme ça et qu'il bouge et je
suis hyper fier un mât le lendemain ça
marche plus du tout je recommence tout à
zéro et il faut à nouveau que je prenne
le temps de l'observer de décrypter et
d'interpréter ça veut dire que je peux
me tromper mais en tout cas il faut
essayer j'ai pas le choix
et c'est ça vivre avec la diversité des
uns et des autres c'est faire preuve de
souplesse tout le temps
et puis c'est oser dire qu'on ne sait
pas et ça c'est pas facile on a tous un
peu d'orgueil on a du mal à le faire
dans les familles avec autiste on a
souvent constaté qu'il y avait des
différences dans le reste de la fratrie
j'ai pas échappé j'ai deux fils ils sont
complètement différents mon aîné il est
précoce hypersensible c'est pas facile à
vivre en fait parce qu'il est différent
en plus il est à dos et un âge où on
veut être comme tout le monde moi je me
retrouve avec deux enfants complexe qui
ne réagissent pas du tout de la même
manière heureusement je me suis arrêté à
2 je sais pas ce que j'aurais fait avec
un troisième en tout cas je navigue mois
entre deux enfants qui attendent des
choses de leur mère que je suis pas
toujours en mesure de leur donner ni
capable d'ailleurs de leurs données j'ai
du mal à comprendre le dernier j'ai du
mal parfois à comprendre mon aîné et
c'est le moment où il faut que je sois
capable de leur dire là je ne peux pas
je ne sais pas je ne comprends pas je ne
sais pas comment faire j'en suis désolé
mais si tu veux bien on va chercher
ensemble ça rend très humble et puis ça
rend très proches aussi finalement parce
qu'on avance ensemble mais il faut
parfois que je sois capable de dire à
mon fils aîné tu es plus intelligents
que moi tu as des moyens que je ne
possède pas là je ne comprends pas où tu
veux en venir honnêtement je n'y arrive
pas il faut savoir accepter ses limites
il faut savoir les dire et je pense
qu'il ya vraiment pas de quoi s'énerver
nice faire la guerre en étant très
différents et en dix ans je n'y arrive
pas on peut y arriver à fonctionner en
tout cas ensemble alors ce qui est très
drôle et assez intéressant finalement
c'est qu'à force de vivre entre ces deux
êtres complètement différent j'ai pris
l'habitude de trouver des excuses à tout
le monde dans le quotidien on se moque
parfois deux mois mais n'empêche quand
je vois au travail dans la rue n'importe
où les gens c'est vrai que je suis
toujours en train d'imaginer ce qu'ils
peuvent être alors si je vois un
monsieur bizarre je peux tout à fait me
dire il est peut-être précoce
hypersensible hyper stressée cette
caissière qui fait la gueule peut-être
qu'en fait elle a mal au dos depuis ce
matin
ce serveur qui est particulièrement lent
il est peut-être un handicapé ou pain il
ya aussi des emmerdeurs on est d'accord
mais je leur accorde le bénéfice du
doute
communiqué prendre le temps de regarder
l'autre quelqu'un différence c'est
difficile et ça demande aussi de
l'énergie il faut se l'avouer je n'ai
pas toujours
il m'est arrivé de m'énerver contre
monfils parfois c'est trop dur j'essaye
de ne plus le faire il ya des moments je
suis trop fatigué il vaut mieux que lui
disent ça me là je n'y arrive pas je
suis épuisée je ne peux plus je m'en
vais je te laisse avec ta colère ta
douleur mais je ne peux pas faire
autrement et je préfère m'éloigner que
tout raté ou m'énerver et surtout le lui
dire
oser dire quand vous ne savez pas et osé
dire tout court en fait y'a pas meilleur
moyen pour communiquer j'ai une amie
vanessa elle suspecte tout le monde de
regarder son fils handicapé de travers
parce qu'en fait elle est blessée mais
elle ne dit rien moi j'ai pris le parti
inverse j'affiche le problème tout de
suite je dis tout de suite quand je vois
des gens qui sont un peu brusque et un
peu surpris jeudi vous savez mon fils
c'est vrai il n'est pas normal c'est
vrai il un comportement bizarre mais
c'est parce qu'il est autiste handicapés
que j'ai pas trouvé le mode d'emploi il
a l'air mal éduqué mais je ne les ducs
pas je ne sais pas comment faire et
c'est vrai là excusez moi mon fils s'est
mis sur la poussette de votre fils à
vous de votre bébé alors qu'ils y
étaient encore ça lui arrive il le
faisait beaucoup il a encore 15 ans il
le fait encore mais je suis désolé je ne
sais pas comment prévenir ce type de
comportement est bien le fait de le dire
le comportement et l'attitude des gens
change immédiatement les jeunes parents
vont prendre leur bébé de la poussette
et laisser mon fils installé en souriant
parfois ils ne le font pas mais en tout
cas on s'explique
tout ça fini beaucoup plus souvent en
franche rigolade vraiment quand
incompréhension totale parce que j'ai
osé dire c'est vraiment très important
moi je suis arrivé dans les handicaps
par la différence par le biais de mon
fils mais tout ça je ne le voyais pas la
différence on ne la regarde pas on n'ose
pas et c'est ça que je voudrais vous
dire aujourd'hui voyez la différence
quelle qu'elle soit regardez là en face
franchement en plus on est tous
l'handicap et des autres il ya toujours
une différence avec quelqu'un d'autre
moi personnellement mais c'est quelque
chose que je ne sais pas faire je ne
sais pas conduire et parler en même
temps pourtant je suis une femme je
devrais savoir faire plusieurs choses je
vous assure que parfois je voudrais
aller à roissy je peux me retrouver
direct sur la route paris bordeaux tout
ça parce que je suis en train de parler
avec mon voisin hélas ce moment là je
suis contente que mon voisin ne s'énerve
pas ne sur réagissent pas
sur réagir
c'est quelque chose qu'on est obligé
d'apprendre à faire dans les handicaps
aujourd'hui on sûr réagi pour tous moi
dans l'autisme j'ai appris à ne pas le
faire alors je vous assure un ça
m'arrive je suis pas wonder woman donc
de temps en temps aussi je part en
vrille mais j'essaie parce que parfois
j'en ai assez que monfils se mettent pas
à mon niveau j'aimerais bien que les
rôles s'inversent évidemment je sais que
ça ne marchera pas mais j'ai appris que
su réagir c'était non seulement
inefficace mais c'est totalement
contre-productif si je m'énerve contre
monfils il va s'énerver dix fois plus il
va me pourrir ma journée il va me
pourrir ma nuit je serai crevé et le
lendemain on rentre dans un cercle
infernal direct donc il ne faut
absolument pas su réagir ça c'est dans
ma situation maintenant je vais vous
emmener vous dans une autre situation
dans laquelle vous sur réagissez en
permanence je vous ramène dans vos
voitures avoue lieu d'énervement maximum
allez savoir pourquoi tout le monde crie
tout le monde s'énerve tout le monde
insulte tout le monde essayait dans
votre voiture de faire preuve
d'imagination
mettez-vous 30 secondes à la place de ce
monsieur là qui vous a fait une embardée
vous appris votre classe s'est mis
devant vous sans prévenir vous avez
frôlé peut-être vous avez eu peur en
tout cas mais peut-être que ce monsieur
là on sait jamais il est peut-être en
train d'emmener sa femme pour accoucher
et qu'il est panique peut-être pas mais
là encore on peut lui accorder le
bénéfice du doute
et on pourrait surtout remplacer ceux ci
part cela
j'ai essayé de trouver le sourire
sympathique le plus différents possibles
en gros il faut qu'on essaie de sortir
de ce cercle vicieux ne me regarde pas
je ne regarde pas les autres je ne tente
pas de comprendre les autres c'est pas
ça la vie en société alors que vous le
savez bien dans le fond si vous souriez
aux autres les autres vont vous sourire
si vous voulez regarder si vous vous
intéressez à eux ils vont s'intéresser à
vous c'est l'effet miroir on m'a demandé
de donner mon avis sur le monde de
demain moi je suis à la fois très
optimiste et très inquiète alors je suis
optimiste parce que c'est ma nature et
que je pense qu'il ya plein de bonnes
choses en chacun de nous je suis
inquiète parce qu'on vit tous dans nos
petits mondes parfois même très très
petit mais je pense que dans le fond il
faudrait pas grand chose pour qu'on y
arrive tous ensemble on ne profite pas
de la diversité dans un groupe c'est
vraiment dommage le groupe pourrait être
génial si on acceptait la différence si
on additionnait au lieu de soustraire je
vous remercie de m'avoir écouté de
m'avoir regardé et je vous suggère de
faire la même chose tout le reste de la
journée merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]